[Music]
al hamdulillah Salaam alaikum peace be
unto you welcome to the Deen show with
me on the D show today we got them back
for another Q&A session my good friend
good brother share yasser hardy assalamu
alaikum peace be unto you how are you
say hum did i'm doing fine alright is i
thank you once again for being with us
with my pleasure eddie thank you thank
you so much as Uggla hide them we invite
you back to do another Q&A session for
those of you who know my good friend
good brother here shake yeah so Karthi
but for those of you don't we're going
to take about 20-30 seconds to let you
know who is right
[Music]
- hey
[Music]
I should help us not see me dreaming for
all right now you know the who do the
shake is where he studied and that we
don't like I said before I have a car
mechanic here given us this Nicaea
advice answers to these very important
questions we're going to get right down
to it I encourage you to keep your
questions coming in this way it's a
great way for all of us to learn because
we're sincerely trying to know the truth
and what better way asking those who are
the most qualified okay so we're going
to get right down to it wasting no time
I'm going to ask you some questions if
you can fry wait you guys are asking
okay these aren't my questions we're
going to ask now first question what
should I do about my prayer what should
I do about do her the afternoon prayer
because at that time I'm in school okay
well realize that every single prayer of
the five prayers has a beginning and
time obviously as we all know therefore
you need to look at firstly are you
going to get back home in time before
the beginning of the next prayer which
is awesome generally speaking generally
speaking you know I think that 95% of
people you know children and teenagers
and college level kids who go to school
will be able to get back home before the
Tepig inning of the Oslo prayer so it
happens it either they should be fine
there if there is a certain special
school or a certain area of the line
where you know also prayer finishes
before school finishes in this case
really you should try as a Muslim you
know in your school to ask the principal
ask the teacher can I get five minutes
off to pray for her and I don't think
there should be a problem where there's
a will there's a way if you can get time
off to go to the bathroom for lunch for
this or that surely they'll give you
five minutes for your lower prayer so
really I think that if this is going to
be a habitual things such as a lower
prayer of the year I don't see any
excuse to try to combine or to do
anything like this rather either pray it
at home before Auslan or if it's going
to be you know conflicting of the very
timings and make sure you find a place
in the locality for example people that
work generally when you're working you
go beyond also for you therefore find a
place where you can pray and you know in
North America at least you're
constitutionally you know
guaranteed the right to be able to pray
no matter what your job is you can take
a few minutes off to go and pray and
then come back in Charlotte okay good
answer to a very good question asking
your questions here on the Dean show all
right next question is taken a loan from
the bank it's taken a loan from the bank
for a house or car consider Dibby okay
realize whether the sister is that there
is no difference of opinion at all
amongst the scholars of Islam today that
a mortgage is River there's no
difference opinion at all the only
different comes are we allowed and
permitted to take this River alone to
buy at the house that we live in or not
in other words is there such a dire need
to take this loan that it becomes
permissible nobody says the loan is
permissible from the beginning nobody
says that this is an okay transaction
you see the only difference is does it
become okay because there is such a
difficult circumstance it's like when
you're about to die and you have pig
meat in front of you
nobody says pig meat is allowed but when
you're about to die then you're allowed
to eat that pig because otherwise you're
going to die okay
the issue is according to the scholars
are we in such a difficult situation
right now that it can be raised to that
level where the the Haram becomes halal
where the prohibited becomes permissible
so some oedema I would say a minority
have said that the situation in North
America is so difficult in Europe and
other places where a minority the per
the the cost of housing is so high it's
astronomical it takes you know 20-30
years for a person to be able to you
know slowly but surely pay that low
enough to get a house and you might as
well be paying for that some of them
have said you know may Allah forgive you
but just gonna go and do it for the
house you live in not for business not
for a car for the house you live in but
having said that that's a minority
opinion okay
I personally you know don't favor it too
much because the issue of interest is a
very severe issue and as I said no two
scholars have differed that a mortgage
is RIBA that a mortgage is interest how
can it not be when the bank says I'll
pay you a hundred thousand you pay me
back one hundred fifty thousand over
twenty five years
this is the essence of interest that's
exactly what interest is so many people
are confused and they say Oh some
said mortgages are our Hallel no it's
not that simple
nobody has set a mortgages Hallel
unconditionally rather what they're
saying some of them are as I said
minority mortgages are permitted for
specific reasons and to specific people
mortgage is how long just like pig is
how long but it might become halide
according to those scholars if you're
living in north america and you have
difficult situation you can't afford to
rent for 20 years and you just want to
buy that one house you live in they'll
say it's like that pigs meat in that
situation you can just do it for that
situation it doesn't become allowed for
it forever it's just for that situation
you know male not forgive you and you
have to do it
the majority of scholars always they
still say no for most people renting is
a difficulty but it's not impossible
if you rent you know year after year
sure you're going to be you know losing
if you like money but it's still you can
still live reasonably if one third of
your income for example is going into
rent you still have two thirds for
groceries and for the rest of your
living expenses so I personally would
say that the general rule should be that
no you know mortgages would not be
permitted to the people because it's
clear-cut hollom it's like alcohol it's
like you know you know dead meat is like
pig meat it's it's in fact to be honest
the prohibition of interest is more
severe than the prohibition of dead meat
of fornication of many of the sins in
Islam because Allah says in the Quran
that whoever takes or eats interest it's
as if he's declaring war against Allah
and His Messenger
if you want to take or receive interest
you want to play around with interest
you might as well say oh Allah I am
challenging you to a battle I was of
Allah seek Allah's refuge from even
think that but that's what the Quran
says test it to take the sin of interest
lightly really the Quran and Sunnah is
very clear interest is not just a major
sin it is one of the most major of all
matrices it's not just any trivial sin
it's a major sin but not just any major
sin the major centers like fornication
that's a major sin problem but interest
is even a higher level than that
therefore for somebody to say you know
what interest is permitted for all
Muslims living in North America
I think that's personally speaking
that's just my personal opinion with all
due respect to those who have said it
think that's broadening it too much and
making it a little bit 2 lakhs rather I
would say the general rule is that we
should rent as much as possible so like
you said the RIBA the interest today is
the same River that's talked about in
the Quran
no difference in opinion about that no
dog was there no okay it wasn't just a
side note on the side that it was
actually prohibited in a lot of the
countries in this country and other
countries just how long ago and what was
that true yeah for I think up to you
know the 17th I'm not sure exactly but
I'm it was since Christianity and
Judaism also prohibits you know interest
it does doesn't it does yeah since it
also bears interest then this was
something that even Western countries
had prohibited for many many centuries
it's only recently I don't know the
exact tip it's only the last two or
three centuries were you know it has
become completely acceptable as not even
you know you don't even find Christians
generally saying that this is not
allowed you didn't find juicing it's not
allowed even though few hundred years
ago it was their own priests and rabbis
who you know were the most against it
okay great that's quite simple now all
right nicely put great question
wonderful answer going to go to the next
one okay you're asking the questions
here on the D so please keep sending
them in okay Wow good question here Oh
unique question what is it about the
woman that draws you to look at her as a
magnet draws metal why is this it's so
hard so I'm sure the mannequin obviously
been asked by a you know a young man who
is just at the prime of his manhood
anything why is it that I never get
satisfied with women no matter how much
I look at them I want to look at the
more and more like what draws you to
look at them why it is something like
pull you to look at it it's very simple
and that is that this is an innate
feeling that men have for women and also
women have for men and were it not for
this feeling humanity would cease to
exist
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala created a
natural urge in each gender to be
attracted to the other if it were not
for that urge marriage would not occur
intimacy would not occur children would
not be born think about it if we didn't
love that other person why would we
spend so much energy and money and and
sacrifice and you know we change your
whole lives to please our partners you
know and then having children you know
if we didn't have love for those
children the amount of stress the
children get a preference the amount of
money the amount why would we do that if
it weren't for that love but Allah
subhanAllah how to put that love in us
put that attraction in it because that's
the way we're going to survive as a
species so the way you're feeling
towards women my dear brother in Islam
is natural what's unnatural is if you
just let it just go all out what you're
feeling is natural yes but the problem
is if you just say you know what I'm
feeling I want to just take it all out
and do whatever I want no just like we
have a feeling to eat and drink but we
keep it in check we eat was permitted
and we await a void that which is in
permitted we eat in moderate quantities
and we don't just splurge everything
similarly we have a desire for the
opposite gender
ahem did Allah go for it get married
find the spouse of your choice and you
know live a beautiful life and be you
know intimate with your spouse and do
whatever you want with them that's all
permitted permitted but to go beyond
that that's where the transgression
occurs
ok a good question a great answer going
on to the next question you guys are
asking them here on the Dean's show keep
sending them in can I pray all my
prayers before I start my day or when I
get home since I'm busy earning a living
during the day no you can't the short
and simple answer no you can't not at
all rather as Allah says in the Quran
that in the Salah taken at al-madinah
catawba makuta that every single prayer
allah has given it a very specific time
there is nothing that is more important
than the prayer not your livelihood not
your sustenance rather Allah says in the
Quran that the believers are those men
who their businesses don't distract them
from the worship of Allah from the
prayer from remembering Allah this is a
verse in the bond believers are the men
you know that they can control their
desire for this world and their there
their businesses and their fortunes they
say you know what it's time to pray I'm
going to go pray you have to cut off
from this world in just five minutes
just five minutes a Allah look for the
sign in front of my lord when I say my
setup I go back to my world no problem
but just for those timings I have to get
out of this world inshallah min and
enter the real world which is the world
of the art of the spirituality the
connection between you and Allah the
short answer is no you have to pray
everywhere this proper time having said
that it is the mercy of Allah that every
single prayer has a beginning and end
time there's a window remember I mean
realize if Allah had willed he could
have said everybody has got to pray
forward exactly at 12:50 - imagine if
that were the case wherever we are in
the world exactly at that time we would
have just had to stop everything go and
pray but Allah is merciful he said no
pray between x and y timing and
generally x and y timing is 3 4 5 hours
sometimes 6 7 hours like between Mazel
TOF agilent between asia and five six
seven hours sometimes anytime between
these two timings pray the prayer so
there's a window and this is of the
mercy of allah spatter without that has
given us this window to praying okay
next question we'll try to get to these
before we close is growing a beard fart
really first and foremost we have to
prioritize that which is for not all
fourth is the same so when a brother
comes and asked me you know is it
obligatory for me to grow the beard
firstly as I asked him I asked him back
are you praying five times a day I think
if he goes no I say worry about your
prayer before you jump to the beer you
know you know I asked him some simple
questions how is your relationship with
Allah subhana wa tada
you know because one of the problems is
that you have this Imam comes and he
goes everybody's got to grow the beard
and he gives a hope about the beard but
there are people sitting in that Juma
prayer they never come to the mosque
except for Juma
they never pray to Allah except for that
Juma subhanAllah are you going to worry
about the beard or worry about the five
prayers you know so its initial
priorities is that you work your way up
you build your way up if a person is
involved you know drinking you know
taking drugs womanizing you don't
concern you
with the beard make sure you'd be a
better Muslim if a person's cheating
stealing lying you being a bad person
you know you go priorities once a person
has done all of that then you know he
comes to stage where he's a good Muslim
he's has a relationship with the law now
he comes in he says you know well you
know do I need to grow a beard or not I
say the classical opinion you know for
the last 14 centuries has been that yes
a man should show his manhood you know
through you know in the through the peer
this is something that the profitsystem
wanted his followers to do is to
basically grow a beard now what defines
a beard there's a huge difference
opinion how big how leave these
differences just grow something called a
beard that's it you know don't worry
about how long or short or taller to
adjust just grow something called a
beard this is the majority opinion there
are a minority of scholars who have said
that this is just a recommendation it's
not obligatory but I personally lean
towards the majority opinion which is
that really it is an obligation upon men
to grow the beards but remember it is an
obligation that is not as strong as many
of the other obligations so prioritize
these obligations okay a lot of these
questions were much longer but for the
sake of time I try to shorten them is
listening to music okay as long as
there's no cursing in the songs
listening to music I mean this is
something that peril in our times
you know when you give the the standard
opinion people find this strange the
standard opinion has been throughout our
history and the four schools of suddenly
thought has been that music is something
that is prohibited in Islam this has
been the standard opinion there have
been probably three scholars in history
famous scholars who have disagreed we
have had tens of thousands of scholars
of the shaft ferry and the Maliki and
the humbly and the hanafi madhhab these
are all famous schools of legal law in
Islam they all have the opinion that
listening to music is something that
should be avoided when you hear this
opinion now people are like what the
heck is lum prohibits music I mean come
on what type of religion is this you
know what could you do it's just as it
moves it makes me feel good
the reason is that
as even mr. hoot said and many of the
famous scholars of the past said that
the heart is only like one vessel it's
only one fragile vessel you can only
fill it with the love of one thing and
if you fill it with the love of music
you're going to block it from the love
of the port on
that's what even my suit said that if
you love music you're not going to love
the quran and if you love the quran then
you're not going to love music and this
is something that really and truly I
know from experience and I know a lot of
people have told me this from their
experiences as well when you love
hearing the [ __ ] and when you love to
hear the speech of Allah being recited
and you're just entranced by it when you
hear music your heart just crumbles it
feels weird it shudders you don't like
it anymore you just it doesn't bring you
the peace that the Quran brings you
conversely when you're addicted to music
and you're totally into music the Quran
will not have much of an effect on you
you can listen to it one ear and out the
other it doesn't have any effect on you
and I've noticed this in my own life and
in the life of many of the people who
are close to me also I want to point out
that don't be so shallow do your
research there are many many scientific
research papers out there that have
documented the effects of music on the
human body all of them is that it
changes your palpitation changes your
heartbeat of them is that you know music
of a certain rhythm will actually
release certain you know hormone certain
you know a certain chemicals that alter
your it that's why music gives you a
high it's not just something that you
feel like it's actually chemical so the
point being when you attune your body to
be affected by music what you're doing
is exactly what even miss root said is
that you're going to just cut it off
from being attuned to the pull on okay
so it's not that simple and there are
many other ways to appreciate the beauty
of Allah it's not just through this
thing appreciate it through nature
appreciate it too this beauty beautiful
creation around you you know the stars
and the trees and the and you go travel
in the line Allah says go sightsee goes
go travel in the land go you know do
other things that are permissible so
those of you who want to like you know
rest their souls and
appreciate you know all of this
beautiful creation of Allah there are
many ways to do so that doesn't involve
that which might be harmful and music is
one of those things that really and
truly you know if it's an either/or
situation if you love music you're going
to deprive yourself from the speech of
Allah if you love the speech of Allah
you have no need for the the false highs
that this thing known as music is for
those another point music has always
historically you know and and the times
we live in always been associated with
sex and interaction with the opposite
gender and other held on and that is why
most music look at our other below the
music videos of our times
look at how they basically you know what
is the content it's always about lust
and extramarital and premarital sex is
always about interaction of the opposite
gender very rarely do you find a
musician who actually has a higher goal
in life look at the music videos and how
they look at women and how they treat
women it does a little bit like
disgusting and now person comes and says
yes this is freeing my soul watching
this filth and garbage of such you know
nudity and an evil talking what not this
is the general rule of music you can
quote me exceptions but these are
exceptions that prove the rule music has
always been associated historically and
in our times with oppression of women
that's why you have music when you have
females dancing around showing their
bodies look at is this feminization is
this freedom of women or liberation or
is it oppression that's natural that
music is associated with that
likewise with making your your passions
flare up and being attracted to the
opposite gender and doing things you
don't want to do music does that that's
why to this day you know look where
music is played where nightclubs where
bars and disco all these places where
fahisha where evil is rampant you don't
find that taking place you don't find
for example that type of music being
played in any serious gathering even of
you know non-muslims oh you don't find
that type of gathering where you know
the president's going to come where
is going to come and that type of music
is blaring in the background you don't
do you because even they realize there's
a time and place for that and whether
there's something serious something of
importance that is not done so this is
something that you know historically has
been the case in to this day and of
course we don't need all of that the
Quran and Sunnah is quite clear on this
it's clear enough that the majority of
the scholars when I say the majority I
literally mean 99% for schools of
thought so for schools of thought all of
them have concurred and have come to the
conclusion that music should be avoided
and you mentioned just for some of our
viewers who don't know who even Massoud
is even Massoud is the famous companion
at the prophet sallallaahu said the
friend companion of the companion of the
process and he's one of the earliest
converts to Islam and he said that you
know whoever has a lot of music in his
heart will not have a lot of quran and
there many other you know instances of
the companions when they pass by music
is being played one of them put his
hands in his ears i don't want to hear
this stuff you know it's gonna affect me
i don't want it to happen it's something
that they understood to this day we all
know those of us were into music when
you hear a tune it brings back memories
where you were before you when you it's
in your brain all the time is going
around all the time you memorize it
you're always thinking about it you go
to sleep and that tune is in your
imagine instead of that tune if you have
the book of a lone yes imagine where you
would go and what it would lead you to
so really you know it's something that
we know from experience that this is
something that there's not good no no
good comes out of this okay couple more
questions and we're going to come to a
close is smoking cigarettes haram uh
there's a general rule islam and that is
that you're asking all the controversial
question by the way it is like every
single controversial let's just come out
and ask as kids a particular okay
there's a general rule in islam and that
is that anything that is harmful to the
body uh would be prohibited anything
that's harmful to the body that's
because allah blessed you with this
beautiful thing called life okay he
blessed you with this body with this you
know this this creation this is you know
this life itself for you to come and
harm it intention
is prohibited therefore anything that
would be deemed harmful Sharia has
completely prohibited it in our tent
once upon a time the dangers of smoking
were unknown to the scholars there for a
hundred years ago
smoking was considered to be yeah you
should avoid it looks like you're
wasting time when he doesn't look very
good but in our times when the dangers
of smoking are very clear I mean there's
you know documented and nobody denies
this anymore the smoking leads to lung
cancer you know these two this leads to
that nobody denies it and that's why you
know even in western lands when you buy
a packet a cigarette from the government
you're told this that product might
possibly kill you don't buy it the
government tells you that you know you
don't need a scholar to come and tell
you don't waste your time your money
your body doing things that's only going
to cause you harm
nowadays the general opinion amongst the
scholars is that smoking is prohibited
okay last question we're going to come
to a close
I pray but I'm nervous to wear hijab
because people my friends and parents
will make fun of me but Allah forgive me
as long as I pray is that a good excuse
not to wear hijab okay
and with that very last controversial
question that you add yourself to
whatever idea came this should be called
the controversial Q&A sessions okay
firstly I'd like to congratulate the
sister for at least getting the
priorities straight and that is to get
the prayer get the prayer in okay
because once you have the prayer down at
home did not happen today you've gone
too far far step forward I'm not saying
you've reached the conclusion I'm not
saying that's it but I'm saying if you
have the five prayers down at home did
Allah that's a very very big thing you
know now it comes to the issue of hitch
up the issue of hijab realize that I
mean I have fully sympathized with the
sisters of our times it's something it's
a badge of honor and courage I mean any
sister that I see wearing hijab out
nothing but respect for her because she
is showing her dedication to Islam 24/7
to me she's showing her Islam more than
any brother can because you know she's a
woman which means physically she's not
as strong as a man emotion she's not as
strong as a man and yet she has the
courage and the audacity to proclaim to
anybody who sees her I am
Muslim and I'm proud of it so any sister
that does that
masha'Allah you know I have nothing but
respect for her sisters who don't do
that I sympathize with them I sympathize
I can't criticise it's difficult I don't
know what I would do in that situation
but all I say is sister turned to Allah
make duaa to Allah pray to him to give
you that courage that you need and in
the meantime in the meantime realize
that if you can't wear that headscarf at
least try your best to wear loose
clothing you know full full sleeves okay
loose pants or loose skirts even better
and interaction with with the opposite
gender should be very appropriate and
work up the courage don't just say I'm
either going to go all the way or just
be as I am work up the courage bit by
bit you know maybe for example wear the
scarf to the Masjid every time you go
every time you leave your hand semester
you wear the scarf or anybody sees you
in the scarf and the sisters in
mashallah sister you look very good
you know maybe wear it you know to
campus on Fridays and you know it just
makes a tell yourself this is the holy
day I have to be extra religious today
okay so work your way up I'm not saying
it's permissible not to wear the a job
the other days don't get me wrong but
what I am saying is bit by bit slowly
but surely you know try to work your way
up to let you reach the the bare minimum
level and don't be scared of what the
people are going to say about you
because in the end of the day you know
as the saying goes sticks and stones may
break my bones may break my bones but
you know words cannot hurt me no matter
what they say about you no matter what
they talk and they and realize any evil
that they say about you you're going to
get reward for it you know allah subhana
wa ta'ala will raise your rank because
somebody criticized you and you were
able to take that and do it for the sake
of allah so all i can advise your sister
is pray to allah and turn to him and ask
him for the courage and support you need
and then give it a try don't be so
scared give it a try
perhaps the results will surprise you in
sha allah and this is the Huq this is
the truth that he's telling us and i'm
very happy that you took up the the
challenge to answer some of these very
as you select a controversial questions
and please I hope by him
you know trying to help us and you
delivered the truth that you are sincere
enough to accept it and I'd like to
shake your hand thing say thank you just
uh Cola hi oh yeah and also add one more
thing to that we're going to give you a
Lula ok the nudie show t-shirt here wash
owe you [ __ ]
Jessica look at I'll wear it with pride
yeah thank you very much I like to thank
everyone I encourage you to continue
sending us your emails your questions
when I get another opportunity to sit
down with one of our guests who has the
credentials not a car mechanic or an
engineer but a doctor in this field
someone who's qualified to give us these
answers keep sending them in and like we
learned today let's spend more time
getting to know the book of our Creator
the verbatim Word of God
got a lot and I think we'll be better
off in the long run thank you very much
a Salaam alaikum peace be unto you
you